I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey, kiddos. It's Uncle Creed here.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。嘿，孩子们。这里是克里德叔叔。
Buckle up because The Office, ladies, just hit 100 episodes. Amazing. Yay! 100 episodes, baby. I am already starting to cry. This is amazing. I brought champagne. I'm going to open it up.
系好安全带，因为《办公室》女郎迎来了一百集。太棒了。耶！一百集，宝子们。我开始想哭了。这太棒了。我带了香槟。我要把它打开。
Look at this. We're drinking again before 10 a.m. We are because it's 100 episodes and we could not have done this without you guys. We wish you were all here with us. Oh, my gosh. Okay, Jenna, don't be afraid. I've opened champagne before. I'm slightly scared.
看这个。我们在上午十点之前又开始喝酒了。我们确实在喝，因为这是一百集，没有你们大家我们是做不到这一点的。我们希望你们当时都能和我们在一起。哦，天哪。好吧，詹娜，别害怕。我以前开过香槟。我有点害怕。
Oh, you know what? I shouldn't point it towards the glass. Sam, I won't point it towards the glass. I appreciate that. Okay, here we go. Woohoo! Congratulations, Jenna. Congratulations, Sam.
哦，你知道吗？我不应该把它对准杯子。萨姆，我不会把它对准杯子。我很感激。好吧，我们开始吧。呜呼！恭喜詹娜。恭喜萨姆。
Cassie. Cody. Colin. Marissa. Eliana. Hanna. Ainsley. Everybody that helps us make this show. Oh, my gosh. We're going to be celebrating with our team later after we record.
卡西。科迪。科林。玛丽莎。埃利安娜。汉娜。安斯利。每一个帮助我们制作这个节目的人。哦，天哪。录完音后，我们待会儿要和我们的团队一起庆祝。
Yes, and we got some fun gifts. Oh, we do. Speaking of fun gifts, I promise you the bags are unrelated to the gifts, but under the table there. What? Those are for you. Happy 100. Sam?
是的，我们收到了一些有趣的礼物。哦，我们确实收到了。说到有趣的礼物，我向你们保证，袋子和礼物没关系，但是就在那张桌子底下。什么？那些是给你的。庆祝第一百集快乐。萨姆？
Oh, my God. Oh, Sam. It's a... Domino's pizza bag? I promise you the bag. It's the only bag. Did you get us pizza? The bags are unrelated.
哦，天哪。哦，萨姆。这是一个……达美乐比萨袋？我向你们保证这个袋子。这是唯一的袋子。你给我们买比萨了吗？这些袋子没有关系。
How do you have Domino's pizza bag? Sam, get out. Sam, you are the cutest person on the planet. You guys. Okay, how do we describe this? It's one of those tornado bowls. Oh, my gosh. It's like Pam's Art School.
你怎么会有达美乐比萨袋？萨姆，滚出去。萨姆，你真是地球上最可爱的人。你们大家。好吧，我们怎么形容这个？这是一个那种龙卷风碗。哦，天哪。这就像帕姆的艺术学校。
It's Pam's Art School Bowl. Congratulations, guys. Oh, my God. Sam, and he has little bottles of alcohol and straws. Sam, this is the cutest, most thoughtful thing. You are so sweet. Now, remember, the key to a punch is it's literally whatever you want. Oh.
这是帕姆的艺术学校碗。恭喜你们，伙计们。哦，天哪。萨姆，里面还有小瓶的酒和吸管。萨姆，这是最可爱、最周到的事情。你太甜了。现在，记住，潘趣酒的关键在于它字面意思上就是你想要的任何东西。哦。
Oh, my gosh. We can't have a volcano bowl. Okay, we're going to have champagne today. We'll save the volcano bowl for our company get together. Sam, I love it. That is so sweet. Surprise gift under the table. Under the table.
哦，天哪。我们不能有一个火山碗。好吧，我们今天要喝香槟。我们把火山碗留给我们的公司聚会吧。萨姆，我太喜欢了。这太贴心了。桌子底下的惊喜礼物。桌子底下。
This is like Oprah when she's like, look under your chair. You get a car. You get a volcano bowl. Sam, thank you. And we have something for you guys. I can't wait for you to see. But we're going to give it to you all at the same time. That's right.
这就像奥普拉说“看你们的椅子底下”一样。你得到一辆车。你得到一个火山碗。萨姆，谢谢你。我们也有东西要送给你们。我等不及让你们看到了。但我们要同时把它送给你们。没错。
Because Cassie's on Zoom today. Hi, Cassie on Zoom. Hi, guys. You're missing champagne, Cassie. I know. Cheers, Jenna. Cheers, lady. I've got a glass of champagne and a cup of coffee.
因为卡西今天在Zoom上。嗨，Zoom上的卡西。嗨，伙计们。卡西，你错过香槟了。我知道。干杯，詹娜。干杯，女士。我有一杯香槟和一杯咖啡。
Nice way to start the day. Listen, today we will eventually be discussing heavy competition. But we would like to dedicate our fast facts to office ladies today to our 100th episode. That's right. So should we get into it? I can't wait. Fast fact number one, office ladies podcast debuted on October 16, 2019.
开始新一天的好方式。听着，今天我们最终将讨论激烈的竞争。但我们想把今天的“办公室女郎快速事实”献给我们的第一百集。没错。那我们开始吧？我等不及了。快速事实一：《办公室女郎》播客于2019年10月16日首次亮相。
So here we are just a little over two years later, having released 100 episodes. 100. And in December of this year, we will hit 200 million downloads. What? I'm getting on the table. Oh, no. 200 million downloads. I'm on the table.
所以我们现在刚好在两年多一点之后，发布了一百集。一百。今年十二月，我们的下载量将达到两亿次。什么？我要站到桌子上了。哦，不。两亿次下载。我站在桌子上了。
This isn't from champagne. This is excitement. It's an audio program. They cannot see it. I'm on the table. No, I don't know how to get down. She's tangled. Oh, geez.
这不是因为香槟。这是因为兴奋。这是一个音频节目。他们看不到。我站在桌子上了。不，我不知道怎么下来。她被缠住了。哦，天哪。
Oh my gosh. You're my mom. It's Lucy. Your glasses. You're Lucy in our studio. You just full on Tom Cruise that lady. Oh, Tom Cruise did. Oh, no.
哦，天哪。你是我的妈妈。是露西。你的眼镜。你是我们演播室里的露西。你刚才彻底汤姆·克鲁斯了那位女士。哦，汤姆·克鲁斯做过。哦，不。
The couch. Oprah's couch. I know. You did it. Listen, when we started this podcast, we never could have imagined that it would grow this big. I did not imagine it. No.
沙发。奥普拉的沙发。我知道。你做到了。听着，当我们开始这个播客时，我们从未想象过它会发展得这么大。我没有想象过。不。
Or that it would be as popular or that it would resonate with people or that we would have this community that we have. And it means so much to my life. It means so much to me. It has changed my life in all the ways that the office changed my life. This has changed my life as well because it has brought me a job that brings me closer to my family and closer to my best friend. Oh, lady.
或者它会如此受欢迎，或者它会引起人们的共鸣，或者我们会拥有我们现在拥有的这个社群。它对我的生活意义重大。它对我的意义重大。它改变了我的生活，就像《办公室》改变了我的生活一样。这也改变了我的生活，因为它给我带来了一份工作，让我离我的家人更近，离我最好的朋友更近。哦，女士。
Don't make me cry. Well, it's true. I feel the same way. I am just deeply grateful, truly grateful. You guys were so thankful for you, for all of the comments and messages you leave us every week, the things that you share with us. It just means so much to us. And we love doing this.
别让我哭。嗯，这是真的。我有同感。我只是深表感激，真的非常感激。你们大家，我们非常感谢你们，感谢你们每周给我们留下的所有评论和消息，感谢你们与我们分享的点滴。这真的对我们意义重大。我们喜欢这样做。
We love it. I love it. I have a really fun fast fact number two. A fun fast fact. I'm going to take a sip of champagne while you say that. I love our mail. I go through a lot of our mail with Ainsley. Yes.
我们喜欢它。我喜欢它。我有一个非常有趣的快速事实二。一个有趣的快速事实。当你说那个的时候，我要喝一口香槟。我喜欢我们的信件。我和安斯利一起看很多我们的信件。是的。
You go through a lot of our physical mail, Angela. Yes. If you write a letter to the ear wolf offices and send things, I go through that. Jenna and Ainsley go through our digital mail. Yes. That's how we divide it up. In our digital mail, we got a letter from Dr. Peter Tibidow. Dr. Tibidow, I know a lot of Tibidows in Louisiana.
安吉拉，你看了很多我们的实体信件。是的。如果你给耳狼办公室写信并寄东西，我会过目。詹娜和安斯利查看我们的数字信件。是的。这就是我们的分工方式。在我们的数字信件中，我们收到了一封来自彼得·蒂比多医生的信。蒂比多医生，我在路易斯安那州认识很多蒂比多。
Here's what he said, Angela. My wife, daughters, and I notice how much you both love saying two things on your podcast. Oh, no. Oh, no. What? Lady. Oh. And amazing.
安吉拉，他是这么说的。我的妻子、女儿和我注意到你们俩在播客中有多喜欢说两句话。哦，不。哦，不。什么？女士。哦。还有太棒了。
Oh. So, I tracked down just how many times that comes up in the podcast. Oh, Dr. Tibidow. Lady, he tracked it. Was it amazing? It was amazing. He was only able to track up to our 92nd episode. Okay.
哦。所以，我追踪了这句话在播客中出现的次数。哦，蒂比多医生。女士，他追踪了。是“太棒了”吗？太棒了。他只能追踪到我们的第九十二集。好吧。
But over the last 92 podcasts, we have said lady 636 times. Oh. And we have said amazing 786 times. Wow. But he broke it down with charts. The charts are incredible. On average, we say the word amazing 9 times per episode and we say lady 7 times per episode. He said there was a stretch from episodes 31 through 47 where our use of both words
但在过去的92期播客中，我们说了636次“女士”。哦。我们说了786次“太棒了”。哇。但他用图表进行了细分。这些图表太不可思议了。平均每集我们说“太棒了”这个词9次，说“女士”7次。他说从第31集到第47集有一段时间，我们对这两个词的使用
really went up. We said amazing and lady a total of 34 times in the Cocktails episode. What was up with us that day? Well, I looked it up and episodes 31 through 47 ran from June of 2020 to September 2020. Summer. Summer vibes. It was also right in the heart of the pandemic. We were recording from home in our closets.
确实上升了。在《鸡尾酒》那一集里，我们一共说了34次“太棒了”和“女士”。那天我们怎么了？嗯，我查了一下，第31集到第47集的播出时间是从2020年6月到2020年9月。夏天。夏日氛围。这也正值大流行病的核心时期。我们在衣橱里的家中录音。
I think we were coping. I think we were throwing out the ladies to cope. I think amazing because we were in closets and we're like, this is amazing. I think so. Or, you know what I think? What? I think doing our podcast felt amazing and it was such a great healing thing for us through the pandemic.
我想我们在应付。我想我们是在用“女士”来应付。我想“太棒了”是因为我们在衣橱里，然后我们觉得，这太棒了。我也这么觉得。或者，你知道我在想什么吗？什么？我觉得做我们的播客感觉太棒了，这在整个大流行期间对我们来说是一个非常好的治愈的事情。
Really, and truly. It was an escape for me. It was an escape. Like every time I walked into that closet, I was like, I get to hang out with Jenna today. Yeah. And we get to talk about really fun things. And that's really when like Cody and Cassie and Sam and you like became my best friends because you were the only people I ever saw.
真的，确实如此。对我来说这是一个逃避。这是一个逃避。就像每次我走进那个衣橱，我都觉得，我今天可以和詹娜一起玩了。是的。而且我们可以聊一些非常有趣的事情。也就是从那时起，科迪、卡西、萨姆和你就像成了我最好的朋友，因为你们是我见过的仅有的人。
Yeah. On that Zoom. 100%. Yeah. We would start our podcast just sort of sharing. Yeah. Like in school, where you have circle time and you share. Yeah.
是的。在那个Zoom上。100%。是的。我们开始播客时只是在分享。是的。就像在学校里，你围坐在一起分享。是的。
That was the first part of every podcast Zoom. I think that's why we thought they were so amazing. I agree. Well, our biggest lady episode was the coup. We said it 19 times. Made me snort laugh. Our biggest amazing episode was traveling salesmen. We said it 20 times.
那是每次播客Zoom的第一部分。我想这就是为什么我们觉得它们太棒了。我同意。嗯，我们“女士”最多的一集是《政变》。我们说了19次。让我笑得喷鼻息。我们“太棒了”最多的一集是《旅行推销员》。我们说了20次。
But then this was my favorite thing. Oh my gosh. That Dr. Tibido wrote. Dr. Tibido. He said, sadly, there were a few times when the office ladies weren't feeling amazing. And we only used it one time. What? Episode.
但接下来这是我最喜欢的部分。哦，天哪。蒂比多医生写的。蒂比多医生。他说，遗憾的是，有几次办公室女郎感觉并不那么太棒。我们只用了一次。什么？哪一集。
Diversity day, boys and girls, and take your daughter to work day. Wow. And then he says, and lady, there were four podcasts where there was no use. Use of the word lady at all. And those were sexual harassment, booze, cruise, Dwight speech and customer survey. I find it hard to believe that we didn't say lady one time. Yeah. But Dr. Tibido has the stats.
《多元化日》、《男孩女孩日》和《带女儿上班日》。哇。然后他说，至于“女士”，有四期播客根本没有使用过“女士”这个词。它们是《性骚扰》、《酒水游轮》、《德怀特的演讲》和《客户调查》。我觉得我们一次都没说“女士”很难以置信。是的。但蒂比多医生有统计数据。
Well we had to ask Dr. Tibido, why? Why track it? I mean, we love to track stuff, but what compelled him to track all of this? And he said, I am a PhD scientist and I love tracking data of any kind. Oh, Jenna, this is like your soulmate. Am I a PhD scientist on the inside and I don't know it? You love to track things, lady. Maybe I'm a PhD scientist.
好吧，我们不得不问蒂比多医生，为什么？为什么要追踪这个？我的意思是，我们喜欢追踪各种东西，但到底是什么促使他追踪这一切的？他说，我是一名博士科学家，我喜欢追踪任何类型的数据。哦，珍娜，这简直就是你的灵魂伴侣。难道我内心深处也是个博士科学家，而我自己却不知道？你就是喜欢追踪各种东西，女士。也许我真的是个博士科学家。
Maybe you are. He said, for whatever reason, this is something that my family and I caught on about early and I took this on just to see how it went. And I will do this all the way to the end and I will never miss an episode. Dr. Tibido, we have got to send you a lady sweatshirt. Wait, we're going to send your whole family lady sweatshirt. Yeah, everybody gets a lady sweatshirt. Thank you.
也许你真是。他说，不管出于什么原因，这是我和我的家人很早就开始关注的一件事，我接手这个只是为了看看进展如何。我会一直坚持到最后，绝不错过任何一集。蒂比多医生，我们一定要送你一件女士卫衣。等等，我们要把女士卫衣送给你们全家。没错，每个人都有一件女士卫衣。谢谢。
Thank you so much, Dr. Tibido. That piece of mail, it made my day. I want to see the bar graph chart. I want to see it. We got to put it. We'll post it. Oh, we'll put it in stories. Let's do it.
非常感谢你，蒂比多医生。那封邮件真的让我的一天都变得美好了。我想看那个条形图。我一定要看看。我们得把它放出来。我们会把它发到动态里。我们就这么办。
And his daughter made some graphics to go along with the facts and we can put those up as well. I love this family. Same. Now, Angela, you said save me a fast fact. So you are fast fact number three and I don't know what it is. Yes, Jenna. Fast fact number three and I want to give a huge shout out to our Office Ladies podcast
他的女儿还制作了一些图表来配合这些事实，我们也可以把它们放上去。我太喜欢这家人了。我也是。好了，安吉拉，你刚才说给我留一个快速事实。所以你是第三个快速事实，而我还不知道内容是什么。是的，珍娜。第三个快速事实，我想向我们的Office Ladies播客
fan page over on Facebook and they submitted a song to celebrate our 100th episode. We have to hear it. Okay. Now, have you heard this yet? Because I have not heard this. I have not heard it. I wanted us to hear it together in real time for the first time. All right.
在脸书上的粉丝专页表达巨大的感谢，他们提交了一首歌曲来庆祝我们的第一百集。我们必须听听看。好的。现在，你听过这个了吗？因为我还没听过。我也没听过。我想让我们俩在实时中第一次一起听。好的。
So here we go. Five hundred and eighty four thousand eight hundred seconds. That's how many seconds are in the podcast. We've all been listening every Wednesday in fast facts and deep dives with guest doors and cantapedia new plans and reception and heartbreak in the break room 584,800 seconds that's like watching the office only two times you have a bunch of cats and one native bird you helped us with our backpacks and showed us just what we're worth you've inspired us oh we thank you so much oh we're all who worked on the pot all one hundredth episode celebration
那么我们开始了。五十万八千四百秒。这就是播客里的秒数。我们每个星期三都在收听，在快速事实和深度剖析中，有门卫和坎塔佩迪亚，新计划和前台接待，还有茶水间的伤心事。五十万八千四百秒，那就像只看了两遍《办公室》。你有一群猫和一只本地鸟，你帮我们背包，展示了我们的价值，你激励了我们，哦，我们非常感谢，哦，我们所有参与播客的人，庆祝第一百集
celebrate celebrate from your office ladies facebook fan page you've inspired us so beautiful you've inspired us oh ladies oh you've inspired us i can't really just checking in we're all crying right we're all crying that was so so kind um my goodness that was so great thank you so much i really want to give a big thank you that was a group effort and i'm going to read off who all was part of that amazing song um these are happy tears guys these are happy tears so hannah byers had the idea for it mackayla and zach dodge who are a husband and wife team performed it and natisse syphony and mackayla dodge wrote the lyrics
庆祝，庆祝，来自你们的Office Ladies脸书粉丝专页，你激励了我们，如此美丽，你激励了我们，哦，女士们，哦，你激励了我们，我简直……等一下，我们在哭对吧？我们都在哭，这太……太暖心了……天哪，这太棒了，非常感谢，我真的想表达巨大的感谢，那是集体合作的结果，我要念出所有参与制作那首神奇歌曲的人的名字……这些是幸福的眼泪，伙计们，这些是幸福的眼泪。所以，汉娜·拜尔斯想出了这个主意，麦凯拉和扎克·多奇是一对夫妻档，他们进行了表演，娜蒂斯·西夫尼和麦凯拉·多奇写了歌词
isn't that wonderful and i also know a lot of you guys on the facebook page are sending in messages thank you so much michelle nicky and brad are helping me and we're going to put all of your messages over the next few days into our insta stories thank you so much office ladies facebook fan page i'm still kind of speechless i know pretty much wept through that whole thing you really got me with the cat eating the bird and and the backpack that's a reference to a bonus episode that we did where i shared a little about my social anxiety and my coping mechanisms and um that was a really vulnerable thing when i shared that and i i questioned doing it and just to um anyway that just meant a lot i know i know lady i know and just when you had us crying you told us
这不是很棒吗？我也知道你们脸书专页上的很多人都在发信息，非常感谢米歇尔、尼基和布拉德在帮我，我们将在接下来的几天里把你们所有的信息发到我们的Instagram快拍中。非常感谢Office Ladies脸书粉丝专页，我现在还是有点说不出话来。我知道，我几乎把整首歌都听哭了。猫吃鸟和背包那段真的戳到我了，那是对我们做过的一个番外篇的致敬，我在那里分享了一点关于我的社交焦虑和应对机制，那是一件非常脆弱的事情，当我分享的时候，我曾质疑过这样做是否合适，总之……那意义重大。我知道，我懂，女士。我知道，就在你把我们弄哭的时候，你告诉我们
that basically if you've listened to office ladies you've only watched the office twice i love that okay well gosh i think we need a minute i think we need a minute let's take a break and when we come back we will dedicate the rest of this episode to breaking down heavy competition all right we are back we've had a laugh we've had a cry we've had a little champagne that's really good thank you champagne it is brute classique well by france war i'm always classic baby you know what my eyesight's so bad i can't read it it's all right but it's very good it's france war that's what we need to know by the way during break both sam and jenna we're just
基本上，如果你听过Office Ladies，你其实只看过两倍的《办公室》。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，天哪，我想我们需要一分钟。我想我们需要一分钟，我们休息一下，等我们回来后，我们将把这集剩下的时间用来剖析《激烈的竞争》。好了，我们回来了，我们笑过了，我们哭过了，我们还喝了一点香槟，这酒真不错，谢谢你。香槟，这是干红起泡酒，来自法国沃区。我一直都很古典，宝贝。你知道我的视力太差了，我都看不清。没关系，但这真的很好，这是法国沃区产的，这就是我们需要知道的。顺便说一句，在休息期间，萨姆和珍娜一直在
making fun of me getting on the table well because it's um you know it's a podcast i know it's a podcast we appreciated it 200 million downloads that's a big deal i knew i had to do something i was like i gotta do something what do i do what i appreciated the energy i did i appreciated it well you always show up with that thank you sam videoed it cassie took photos it'll go in the pod stories should we break down heavy competition do it this is season five episode 24 written by ryan co and directed by ken wittingham i'm gonna give you a summary do it michael forces dwight to choose between either his loyalty to charles minor and dunder mifflin or michael and this results in the two of them going to war yeah and michael trying to steal dwight's top clients
取笑我爬到桌子上。好吧，因为……你知道的，这是一个播客。我知道这是一个播客。我们很感激。两亿次下载，这是一件大事。我知道我得做点什么，当时我就想，我得做点什么，我该做点什么？我很欣赏这种活力，真的，我很欣赏。好吧，你总是带着这种活力出现。谢谢你。萨姆录了视频，卡西拍了照片，它会进入播客的快拍中。我们要不要开始剖析《激烈的竞争》？开始吧。这是第五季第二十四集，由瑞安·科编剧，肯·威丁汉执导。我来给你们做一个总结。讲吧。
it's gonna get ugly it's a heavy competition yeah and still hurting from his breakup with angela andy suspects that maybe pam is being controlling of jim maybe mistreating him so he starts offering jim a bunch of unsolicited advice which backfires when jim pranks him into confiding that things are terrible between him and pam it starts this whole runner yeah but this episode begins with a very famous cold open the cheese puff cold it is i titled it the cheese puff i loved doing this cold open i have so many questions for you i have so many questions should we describe it describe it all right it's pam michael and ryan tossing cheese puffs into one another's mouths in various ways right it's like the things you see on like youtube
迈克尔迫使德怀特在效忠查尔斯·迈纳与邓德·米夫林之间，还是效忠迈克尔之间做出选择，这导致他们两人开战，并且迈克尔试图抢走德怀特的顶级客户。
of where the guy bounces the basketball off like the back of a wall and it hits the other side of the wall and it goes in the hoop that's what you guys are doing what you're doing it with cheese puffs and i love the callback because remember this is what michael took when he ran out of dunder mifflin on that last day you have questions we got a fan mail flurry about this so first we reached out to writer ryan co to find out like what was the inspiration for this cold open his response was so funny it's so good i actually spit out my coffee while listening to it yeah we gotta play it hi jenna hi angela thanks for letting me talk about my episode jenna you had mentioned that you love shooting that cold open with the cheese balls and you
事情会变得很棘手，这是一场激烈的竞争。安迪仍然因与安吉拉的分手而伤心，他怀疑彭可能会对吉姆有控制欲，可能对吉姆不好，于是他开始给吉姆提供一堆未经请求的建议，结果适得其反，吉姆恶作剧地让他吐露说他和彭之间的关系糟糕透顶，这引发了整个支线剧情。是的，但这一集是以一个非常著名的冷开场开始的——奶酪泡芙冷开场。确实如此，我把它叫做“奶酪泡芙”。我很喜欢拍这个冷开场，我有好多问题想问你。我有好多问题。我们要不要描述一下？描述一下。好的，是彭、迈克尔和瑞安以各种方式把奶酪泡芙扔进彼此的嘴里，对吧？就像你在YouTube上看到的那些视频一样
were wondering where it came from i remember that it was most of all a product of exhaustion i'll back up a bit yeah you know for the first draft of my episode i had written a cold open about how ryan thought pam had a crush on him and no one liked it so it was tossed out and we needed a new cold open and at this point in the season all the writers were really exhausted in season five as you recall we did 28 episodes and they were shot in a 10 consecutive weeks of production then a break so steve could do a movie and then 18 straight weeks of production and other shows i've been on i've told them that there was a stretch of 18 straight weeks of production and they do not believe we did that and sort of sitcoms it's more common to do two or three
一个家伙把篮球从墙的背面反弹出去，然后它击中了墙的另一边并进了篮筐，你们就是这么做的，你们用的是奶酪泡芙。而且我很喜欢这个回忆杀，因为大家还记得吧，这就是迈克尔在最后一天冲出邓德·米夫林时顺手拿的东西。你们有问题，我们收到了关于此事的狂热粉丝邮件。所以首先我们联系了编剧瑞安·科，想了解这个冷开场的灵感来源是什么。他的回答太搞笑了，太棒了，我听的时候差点把咖啡喷出来。是的，我们得放出来听听。嗨，珍娜，嗨，安吉拉，谢谢你们让我谈谈我写的这一集。珍娜，你曾提到你很喜欢拍摄那个带有奶酪球的冷开场，你
weeks on of production and then one week off so that the actors can recover and so the writers can catch up and don't get totally burned out and so 18 straight weeks is a total death march and i remember at that time a writer was going to go down and check out what was going down on set Paul or someone was like do not go down there the actors are tired and are acting like huge ass so yeah i remember this was sort of rough time and so for the last half of season five we were always behind and i feel like we were working 11 or more hours pretty much every single day i remember Mindy was really mad that it meant she had no social life and said something like i'm gonna die alone because of this damn show so anyway we were all very spent and we were trying to come up with
当时想知道灵感是从哪里来的。我记得那主要是疲惫的产物。我倒回一点说。你知道的，对于我这一集的初稿，我写了一个冷开场，讲的是瑞安觉得彭对有好感，但没有人喜欢这个主意，所以它被扔掉了，我们需要一个新的冷开场。在这一季的这个时候，所有的编剧都非常疲惫。正如你们所回想的，在第五季中，我们制作了28集，它们是在连续10周的制作中拍摄的，然后休息一段时间以便史蒂夫去拍电影，接着又是连续18周的制作和其他节目。我曾告诉过我待过的其他剧组，我们曾有过连续18周制作的时期，他们根本不相信我们做过。某种程度上，情景喜剧更常见的是制作两到三
a new cold open and it was either Aaron Scherr or Paul there were both the guys that were really good at making something out of nothing one of them said i don't know they're throwing cheeseballs at each other and everyone's like great we don't have to write anything that's awesome okay that's the cold open cheeseballs all right next as far as anything else about writing the episode it was a long time ago and i don't really remember because i was tired Ryan that made our day i mean i look at this amazing piece of comedy that came out of just everyone being so tired fatigue yes you guys might remember Ryan is our writer who wiped out while running past the speed reader sign yes so Ryan thank you so much for sharing your memory with us
周然后休息一周，以便演员们能够恢复精力，编剧们也能赶上进度，不至于彻底精疲力竭。所以连续18周简直是一场死亡行军。我记得当时有个编剧打算下去看看片场发生了什么，保罗还是谁说：“别下去，演员们很累，表现得像个混蛋。”所以是的，我记得这是一段艰难的时期。因此，在第五季的后半段，我们总是进度落后，我觉得基本上每天都要工作11个小时甚至更久。我记得明迪真的很生气，这意味着她没有社交生活，还说了类似“因为该死的节目我要孤独终老了”这样的话。总之，我们当时都精疲力竭，我们在努力想出一个新的冷开场，当时要么是亚伦·舍尔，要么是保罗，他们两个都是那种非常擅长无中生有的人，其中一个人说：“我不知道，他们在向对方扔奶酪球。”然后每个人都说：“太棒了，我们不用写任何东西了，这太棒了。”好吧，这就是那个冷开场——奶酪球。好了，接下来，至于关于写这一集的其他事情，那是很久以前的事了，我真的记不清了，因为我很累。瑞安，你让我们的一天都变得美好了。我是说，我看着这个精彩的喜剧片段，它竟然诞生于每个人都如此疲惫的状态，疲劳啊。是的，你们可能还记得，瑞安就是那个在跑过测速仪标志时摔倒的编剧。是的，所以瑞安，非常感谢你与我们分享你的记忆。
of the cheeseball cold open and now and sorry if we were assholes that week i guess we were all tired and grouchy i guess so lady you said you had some questions i do i'm here to answer questions all right so i know from other episodes where anytime we had to throw something you don't get it on the first take but that shot of steve throwing the cheese puff ball at you you caught it you chomped it you looked right to camera and i was like my girl look at her i was so proud i was like okay sydney bristo on alias can you do that jenna this is like your moment all right i'm gonna tell you something okay when i was in high school i did not have a vibrant social life so you threw cheeseballs at your face no what i watched a lot of movies
那个无聊的开场白。抱歉如果我们在那一周显得很混蛋，我猜我们当时都又累又暴躁。我想是的。所以，女士，你说你有一些问题。是的，我是来回答问题的。好的，我知道从其他剧集来看，任何时候我们需要扔东西时，你都无法一次通过。但史蒂夫把芝士球朝你扔过去的那个镜头，你接住了它，咀嚼它，直接看着镜头，当时我就想：我的女孩，看看她！我太骄傲了，我就想：这简直是《双面女间谍》里的悉尼·布里斯托。你能做到吗？珍娜，这就像是你的高光时刻。好吧，我要告诉你一件事。好吧，当我在高中时，我并没有丰富多彩的社交生活。所以你把芝士球往自己脸上扔？不！我看很多电影。
okay and when i watched the movies i would eat popcorn and i started throwing the popcorn up in the air and catching it by yourself yeah okay listen it paid off later in my life it sure did it so don't feel sorry for me i'm not feeling sorry i also saw tons of great movies and i have a great mind for the cinema yes so i am really good at catching food in my mouth i know also my sister and i would throw popcorn at each other sure sure so when i read this cold open i was like i'm gonna nail this and then i got really scared that they were gonna want to CGI it because you were like guys i got this it's not CGI no i want everyone to know those are real cheeseballs we had the best time shooting this it looks like it i was just delighted by every moment of it
好的。当我看着电影时，我会吃爆米花，然后我开始把爆米花扔向空中，然后用嘴接住。你自己扔？是的。听着，这在我的后半生得到了回报，确实如此。所以不要为我感到难过，我不难过。我也看过无数伟大的电影，我对电影有着极佳的品味，是的。所以我非常擅长用嘴接食物。我知道，而且我和我妹妹会互相扔爆米花。当然，当然。所以当我读到这个开场白时，我就想，我一定要搞定它。然后我真的很害怕他们会用CGI特效，因为当时你对大家说：伙计们，我能搞定，这不是CGI特效。不，我想让每个人都知道，那是真正的芝士球。我们拍摄时的时光太棒了。看起来确实如此。我被它的每一个瞬间都逗乐了。
jenna i'm great at catching food in my mouth as well but oh just because i have good hand eye coordination because i'm a little bit of a sport oh why have we never thrown food at one i know why what do we have in here can we throw something at each other we have a little bit of granola bar we have granola bar and alcohol that's not gonna work well next time we're bringing popcorn we can film that sam's going to the kitchen so maybe we'll get some food in a second it did take us a whole afternoon to shoot this and the one that took the longest was the three way okay where she's phrased that differently i'm gonna phrase it how i want okay okay okay the one that took the longest was the three way as you were saying continue you know the one
珍娜，我也很擅长用嘴接食物，但是，哦，只因为我拥有良好的手眼协调能力，因为我有点运动细胞。哦，为什么我们从来没向对方扔过食物？我知道为什么。我们这里有什么？我们能互相扔点东西吗？我们有一点格兰诺拉麦片棒，我们有格兰诺拉麦片棒和酒精，这可不行。好吧，下次我们要带爆米花，我们可以把它拍下来。山姆正要去厨房，所以也许过一会儿我们能拿到一些吃的。我们确实花了一整个下午来拍摄这个，其中花时间最长的是三人组……好吧，她用词有点问题。我要按我的想法说。好吧，好吧，好吧。花时间最长的是三人组，正如你所说，继续。你知道那个……
where yes i know like we're each throwing a cheese ball into a different person's mouth you had to time it out and oh oh oh my god rice crispy treats sam brought us rice crispy treats well these hurt our teeth are they free this is gonna hurt all right that's all we have i mean don't throw them hard here you got polo piece okay okay ready yeah one two three oh it was a terrible what was that toss that was a terrible okay wait wait okay okay ready yeah oh the problem is it sticks to your thumb as you're trying to throw it you're doing that so low okay okay here we go she hit me in the eye oh my god okay you try to throw to me wait these are so sticky there's that's when you when you try to throw it you can't it won't leave your finger okay we might need
其中，是的，我知道，就像我们每个人把一个芝士球扔进不同人的嘴里。你必须掌握好时机，然后，哦，天哪，米饼干！山姆给我们带来了米饼干。这会伤到我们的牙齿。它们是免费的吗？这会很痛。好吧，这就是我们所有的了。我是说，别用力扔。来吧，你拿着这一块。好的，好的，准备好。一，二，三。哦，太糟糕了。那是什么投掷？那太糟糕了。等等，等等，好吧，好吧，准备好了。哦，问题是，当你试图扔它的时候，它粘在你的大拇指上了。你扔得太低了。好吧，好吧，我们开始。她打中了我的眼睛！哦，天哪。好吧，你试着扔给我。等等，这些太粘了。当你试图扔它时，它根本不离开你的手指。好吧，我们可能需要……
something other than rice crispy treat bars ah can i just say that was a really good toss it wasn't a good toss why are we doing visual gags on our podcast okay stop okay we're gonna stop okay we got one you guys we got one okay riveting content well throwing rice crispy treats is a little difficult you were talking about the three way oh yeah that was the hardest one you know that reaction that you see at the end when we finally make it yes because you were probably genuinely excited that was real i think you can see the look on my face i knew i caught mine and then i had to look and see if they really caught theirs and then we were genuinely excited that was the only time we ever got that toss correct and they got it on camera they got it
除了米饼干条之外的东西。啊，我能说那是一个非常好的投掷吗？那不是一个好投掷。为什么我们在播客上做视觉噱头？好吧，停下。好吧，我们要停下来。我们成功了一个，伙计们，我们成功了一个。引人入胜的内容。扔米饼干有点困难。你刚才在说三人组。哦，对，那是难度最高的一个。你知道你在最后看到的那个反应，当我们终于成功的时候。是的。因为你可能真的很高兴。那是真的。我想你能从我的脸上看出来。我知道我接住了我那份，然后我不得不看看他们是否真的接住了他们的。然后我们是真的很高兴。那是我们唯一一次把那个投掷做对，而且他们把它拍下来了。他们把它……
on camera but we spent a whole afternoon on the cheese puff sequence we got a fan question from erin b at the end when the cheese ball lands in Pam's hair so perfectly was that in the script or just pure luck that was pure luck it was just supposed to be that each of those guys throw a cheese ball at me when i yawn right i didn't even know it was stuck in my hair it's so perfect because you look directly at camera thinking you brushed the other one off and your cheese ball free yes and then one little dude's hanging in your hair ah without a doubt this was one of my favorite sequences to shoot ever on the office and i feel like it bonded me and steve and bj i would think so in a real way yeah it was a very very fun day at work well now the episode is
拍下来了，但我们在芝士泡芙的镜头上花了一整个下午。我们收到了来自艾伦·B的粉丝提问：在最后，当芝士球完美地落在帕姆的头发上时，那是剧本里写好的还是纯属巧合？那是纯属巧合。本来只是要求那些家伙每个人在我打哈欠时向我扔一个芝士球。我甚至不知道它卡在我的头发里。这太完美了，因为你直接看着镜头，以为你把另一个刷掉了，而且你身上没有芝士球了。是的，然后一个小家伙挂在你的头发上。毫无疑问，这是我在《办公室》里拍摄过的最喜欢的镜头之一，我觉得它以一种真实的方式将我和史蒂夫以及BJ联系在了一起。我想是的。这真的是工作中最有趣的一天。现在这一集要开始了……
going to start jim pam and andy are in the break room i don't even know what to title this break room scene shopping over misery i don't know so andy is showing them photos of wedding cakes he's playing them wedding music basically he's trying to sell off things he paid for for his wedding to angela yeah he's trying to get pam and jim to buy these elements from his not fabon wedding held wedding yeah and one of the things that he plays for them is a song that pam could walk down the aisle to buy his acapella group yes it's sort of a combination of pacabelle that morphs into call me al yes should we hear it i think we need to randy cordray sent us in the whole song let's hear it
吉姆、帕姆和安迪在休息室里。我甚至不知道该给这个休息室场景起个什么名字，也许叫“在痛苦中购物”吧。不知道。所以安迪在给他们看婚礼蛋糕的照片，他在放婚礼音乐。基本上，他在试图卖掉他为与安吉拉的婚礼支付过费用的东西。是的，他在试图让帕姆和吉姆买下他那场未举办的奢华婚礼中的这些元素。其中一件事他放给他们听的是一首帕姆可以伴着走向红毯的歌曲，由他的无伴奏合唱团演唱。是的，这有点像是帕海贝尔的曲子演变成《Call Me Al》。是的。我们应该听听看吗？我想我们需要听。兰迪·科德雷把整首歌发给我们了，我们听听看。
do that's right andy tells pam she can walk down the aisle to this song for the low price of nine thousand dollars which pam says seems like a lot for an acapella group from a college that neither her or jim attended yeah wait before we move on i just want you guys to know i played that this morning in my kitchen and literally was dancing and ed's guitar acapella solo will never ever disappoint if you were having a day where you're down in the dumps listen to ed helms as andy go do you think anyone's ever actually walked down the aisle to this oh i hope so me too oh i hope so if you walk down the aisle to this will you tag office ladies pod please we got a fan question
没错。安迪告诉帕姆，她可以伴着这首歌以九千美元的“跳楼价”走向红毯，帕姆说对于一个既不是她也不是吉姆上过的大学出来的无伴奏合唱团来说，这听起来好像有点贵。等等，在我们继续之前，我只想让你们知道，我今天早上在我的厨房里放了这首歌，当时真的在跳舞，而且埃德的吉他无伴奏独奏永远永远都不会让人失望。如果你正经历着情绪低落的一天，去听听埃德·赫尔姆斯扮演的安迪吧。你觉得真的有人曾伴着这首歌走向红毯吗？哦，我希望如此。我也是。哦，我希望如此。如果你伴着这首歌走向红毯，请给 office ladies pod 标记一下好吗？我们收到了来自哈姆·珍·V的粉丝提问：
from harm jen v did ed helms do all the voices in this acapella song no no he did not he got together a group of his friends to perform this piece he called john michael higgins who did the arrangement and the solo voice in the first section you guys know him he's from all of the christopher guest movies he was also in that movie the break up with vince fawn and jennifer aniston where he's in an acapella group called the tone rangers but he has also appeared or his voice has appeared on a previous episode of the office that's right you guys he was in launch party he and ed sang take a chance on me to angela in that episode over speakerphone yes so he did the lead vocals on this ed did that baseline they recorded it in a studio at universal
埃德·赫尔姆斯唱了这首无伴奏歌曲里的所有声音吗？不，不，他没有。他召集了一群朋友来表演这段作品。他给约翰·迈克尔·希金斯打了电话，后者做了编曲和第一段的主唱。你们认识他，他出演过所有克里斯托弗·格斯特的电影。他还演过那部由文斯·沃恩和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿主演的电影《分手男女》，在片中他在一个名叫“音调游侠”的无伴奏合唱团里。但他还曾在《办公室》以前的一集里出现过，或者说他的声音出现过。没错，伙计们，他演了《产品发布会》。在那一集中，他和埃德通过免提电话为安吉拉演唱了《Take a Chance on Me》。是的，所以他唱了主唱，埃德唱了低音。他们是在环球影城的录音室里录制的。
studios randy told us that they did this in three takes amazing amazing dr tibido amazing well after this episode aired they updated the angela and andy wedding website they posted the whole song along with an advertisement for the acapella group for the wedding services for nine thousand dollars just like andy says in the scene that's incredible well next up we see dwight in a white long sleeve shirt this scene was so funny to me i thought rain was so funny the way he kept struggling in the long sleeve and saying how it was like affecting his attack readiness he said it was like a straight jacket yeah he's in the kitchen he's talking with phyllis i guess this is charles's new dress code yeah i had something happen to me when i was watching this scene
兰迪告诉我们，他们只录了三次就完成了。太惊人了，蒂比多医生，太惊人了！好吧，在这集播出后，他们更新了安吉拉和安迪的婚礼网站，发布了整首歌，以及那首无伴奏合唱团婚礼服务的九千美元广告，就像安迪在场景里说的那样。这太不可思议了。好吧，接下来我们看到德怀特穿着一件白色的长袖衬衫。这个场景对我觉得太搞笑了，我觉得雷恩太搞笑了，他一直穿着长袖衬衫挣扎，说这影响了他的战备状态。他说这就像是一件紧身衣。是的，他在厨房里，正和菲莉丝说话。我猜这是查尔斯的新着装规定。是的。当我在看这个场景时，我身上发生了一件事。
what and i want to apologize for it in advance because it became a little bit of an obsession as i watched this episode what it didn't happen to me until my third time watching the episode what happened i became obsessed with what i believe was my observation that dwight's sleeves are too short oh lord they're too short i think they're not long enough and i found an article that breaks down exactly how long a man's dress shirt should fit it has illustrations okay so i created a photo oh side by side you really did get obsessed i mean i spent way too long on this here is their illustration angela of just right too short and then rain's arm oh now i know that photo is not super convincing i know that but i tracked it through the whole episode and i have more evidence
什么事？我想要提前为此道歉，因为当我观看这一集时，这变成了一种轻微的强迫症。什么事？直到我第三次看这一集时它才发生在我身上。发生了什么？我开始对我认为是我的观察结果着迷，那就是德怀特的袖子太短了。哦天哪，它们太短了。我认为它们不够长。我找到了一篇文章，详细剖析了一件男士正装衬衫应该合身到什么长度，上面还有插图。好吧，所以我制作了一张并排的对比照片。你真的是着迷了。我是说，我在这个上面花的时间太多了。安吉拉，这是他们的插图：正合适、太短，然后是雷恩的手臂。现在我知道那张照片不是很具有说服力，我知道。但我整集都在追踪它，我还有更多的证据。
oh my gosh you and dr tibido well i actually that's so funny that you bring this up because i became obsessed with charles minors shirt oh if you look at his shoulders there's an extra stitching across his shoulder and i think it's because his shoulders were so broad i don't even understand why they would do that except that maybe idris had such broad shoulders they had to have an extra stitch i'm gonna have to go look at that i'm gonna show it to you i will find it because once i saw it i couldn't unsee it okay i have a picture of it jenna please look at this extra stitch and pleat on his shoulder what is that what is that see okay okay we did get a fan question for this scene from evan t and pearl c at two minutes 49 seconds when dwight says
哦天哪，你和蒂比多医生……实际上，你提起这个太搞笑了，因为我对查尔斯·迈纳的衬衫着迷了。如果你看他的肩膀，他的肩膀上有一道额外的缝线，我想这是因为他的肩膀太宽了。我甚至不明白他们为什么要这么做，除非也许伊德里斯的肩膀太宽了，他们不得不加上额外的缝线。我得去看看那个。我要把它指给你看。我会找到它的，因为一旦我看到了它，我就无法忽视它了。好吧，我有它的照片。珍娜，请看看他肩膀上的这道额外缝线和褶皱。那是什么？那是什么？看，好吧，好吧。我们确实为这个场景收到了来自埃文·T和珀尔·C的粉丝提问：在两分四十九秒时，当德怀特说……
his shirt is a straight jacket and then he bumps into some wooden sticks and coffee mugs was that scripted or did that happen by accident because phyllis's reaction is so genuine i looked at the script it was scripted that he would knock over the mugs while struggling mm-hmm when that happens that means there is a person off camera to reset all of those mugs they will take a picture of what that little credenza looked like before the scene starts and then after he knocks it all to the ground they will meticulously reset each item so that when they're in the editing room they can use any part of the top of the scene that there's not like a mug right on the far side that used to be on no bogies that's right no random straw where it shouldn't be mm-hmm i love dwight's talking head
他的衬衫是一件紧身衣，然后他撞到了一些木棍和咖啡杯，那是剧本写好的还是意外发生的？因为菲莉丝的反应太真实了。我看了剧本，剧本里写了他在挣扎时会撞翻杯子。嗯哼。当这种情况发生时，意味着现场有一个不在镜头前的人来重置所有这些杯子。他们会在场景开始前拍一张那个小餐具柜看起来是什么样的照片，然后在它被全部撞到地上之后，他们会一丝不苟地重置每一个物品，以便当他们在剪辑室时，他们可以使用场景顶部的任何部分，比如不会出现原本不在那里的杯子。没有怪异的东西，没错，也没有不应该在那里的随机吸管。嗯哼。我喜欢德怀特的独白……
though when he said when michael was in charge this place was like the roman empire and the wild west and war torn poland and poland there was just a lot going on so what you were to work was the least of anybody's worries and in that chaos i soared in this talking head you can totally see his watch because his sleeves are too short okay okay i just want you to know all right well now michael is going to meet dwight outside by the dumpster mm-hmm dwight tells mike that ed's mike i don't know all right dwight tells michael that ed's tires is looking to make a change so dwight is he's helping him out he is he's giving him some intel inside info and michael gives him six dollars for his trouble well dwight says he doesn't need compensation but he does
不过，当他说“当迈克尔负责时，这个地方就像罗马帝国、狂野西部和饱受战争蹂躏的波兰，还有波兰，那里有太多事情发生了，所以谁去上班成了任何人最不担心的事”，在那种混乱中，我展翅高飞。在这个独白中，你完全可以看到他的手表，因为他的袖子太短了。好吧，好吧，我只是想让你知道。好吧，现在迈克尔要在垃圾箱外面见德怀特了。嗯哼。德怀特告诉迈克，埃德轮胎公司正在寻找改变。所以德怀特在帮他，他在给他一些内部情报。迈克尔为他的麻烦给了他六美元。好吧，德怀特说他不需要报酬，但他确实……
remind michael that he owes him ten dollars from four years ago i know i loved that i had to know if that was scripted because i thought steve was so funny when he was like it's four years ago why won't you let that go was it scripted it was i also want you to know at three minutes and 30 seconds you can clearly see michael's shirt sleeves coming out of his suit jacket but you cannot see dwight's jenna you're on to something you're on to something listen idris had broad shoulders and rain's shirt was it was too short too short you believe me i believe you okay back inside andy is gonna tell jim that he's worried you know pam bosses him around he's really worried that their relationship maybe isn't so healthy and he says listen i know a few things about love
提醒迈克尔，他欠他四年前的十美元。我知道，我太喜欢这个了。我不得不去了解这是否是剧本写好的，因为我觉得史蒂夫当时太搞笑了，他说：“那是四年前的事了，你为什么就不能放过它呢？”这是剧本写的吗？是的。我还想让你知道，在三分三十秒时，你可以清楚地看到迈克尔的衬衫袖子从他的西装外套里露出来，但你却看不到德怀特的。珍娜，你发现了什么。你发现了什么。听着，伊德里斯的肩膀很宽，而雷恩的衬衫……它是太短了。太短了。你相信我吗？我相信你。好吧，回到里面，安迪要告诉吉姆他很担心，你知道的，帕姆对颐指气使。他真的很担心他们的关系可能不是那么健康，他说：“听着，我知道一些关于爱的事……
horrible terrible awful things yeah there's a lot to unpack here andy is projecting his own hurt on to jim because pam shot down this idea of using any of andy's wedding stuff and he thinks jim was bulldozed right so he's turned this into a whole story yeah and jim sees his opportunity now for a day long of pranking yeah because i think jim's a little offended well it is ridiculous yeah he's making a lot of assumptions so now michael is going to take this info that he got from dwight he's headed back to michael scott paper company and he tells pam to give ed's tires a call yeah here's what she needs to say she needs to say that michael scott paper company has fewer clients so they can spend more time with each of them and also somehow
可怕的、糟糕的、糟糕透顶的事。”是的，这里有很多东西需要剖析。安迪把自己的伤痛投射到了吉姆身上，因为帕姆拒绝了使用安迪任何婚礼用品的想法，而他认为吉姆被推土机般强行推过了，对吧？所以他把这变成了一个完整的故事。是的，而吉姆现在看到了进行一整天恶作剧的机会，是的，因为我觉得吉姆有点被冒犯了。好吧，这太荒谬了。是的，他做出了很多假设。现在迈克尔要拿走他从德怀特那里得到的情报，他正朝着迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司走去，他告诉帕姆给埃德轮胎公司打个电话。是的，她需要说的是：她需要说迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司拥有更少的客户，所以他们可以花更多的时间在每个客户身上，并且不知何故……
mentioned she distrusts women and he recommends she do it over indian food pam's like i'm not going to say that ryan's like i can get there that made me laugh out loud this is a little foreshadowing for something that's going to come up later which is that michael takes kind of meticulous detailed notes about each client and he knows meticulous well he knows little details about each one i feel like when i saw michael's rolodex jenna it reminded me of my note cards oh because i usually put a few words that mean something to me right now i put it all in a document but if you look at my notes i give myself words that only mean something to me look next to jim's talking head what does it say boo why does it say boo because i don't know what that means i don't
like jim in this moment i think he's being mean to andy so i wrote boo and then right here what does that say trophy that means something to me we'll get to it but i was like oh my gosh i'm michael scott i have like a few key words well you know in my early actor days when i would go to casting offices i would come home and i had a little card file like a rolodex where i'd write down little notes about anything like that like loves chocolate chip cookies so that the next time i went into that casting office i could have something that might spark yeah i'm a lot of connection you're like hi tammy hadn't you good chocolate chip cookies lately pretty much yes so casual yeah okay so back to the scene i have a little thing i spotted at five minutes nine seconds there is a poster
hanging in the background of the scene it's over to the left of michael's desk it says diversity so that poster was made by phil shay using the hands of our hair and makeup crew yes that is their hands and like i guess their arms right yes yeah so now pam has a talking head they've done their little chant their cheer their morning you ugly cheer yeah yeah and she just said listen she's here she's part of this now that's right and i had a little catch at five minutes and 16 seconds what's a background catch queen this is a on my face catch oh did you notice in this episode that i have a darker pigmented lip and eyeshadow it's a much richer color no i did not oh my gosh okay i noticed because this was a huge thing listen when you had dark nail polish out of
nowhere i noticed i know your lipstick i didn't quite notice we usually alternated between two neutral lip shades but my makeup artist laverne she said i really think we could go a little bolder for pam she made her first sale last week yeah she's got her blazer yeah yeah so how can we continue to tell the story of her growing confidence so we went with a bolder lip i like it thank you our next scene is charles and dwight they're in charles's office note his shoulders please also please note that rain's entire watch is exposed because his sleeves are too short five minutes 39 seconds all right so basically charles wants to know if dwight is happy at the company you know and he invites him out to drinks so in the background of the scene you can see jim
jenna john has angled his computer because he's clearly like surfing the internet or checking email or something so while i was watching the scene the first time i just watched it just to watch it then i was like wait a second john's doing email in the background and the way back this scene also has a line i love when charles says to dwight you're so focused and dwight says like a wolf thank you well rain was asked in an interview what he thought drinks between dwight and charles might entail yeah and this was his answer he said probably charles getting really bored after about eight minutes and making up an excuse to leave he was also asked about his decision to choose dunder mifflin over michael scott paper company what'd he say he said dwight is
loyal to whoever values loyalty the most and in this case dunder mifflin honors loyalty with an actual paycheck and that is why he chose dunder mifflin i also want to point out in this scene that charles is still drinking out of his satacoist steel insulated coffee mug and i have to say i think it's a betrayal you're out of the steel business charles let it go get a dunder mifflin insulated mug already yeah what is your attachment to your satacoist steel yeah you know corporate gave him a mug but he's not using it that's a choice that's what i'm saying yeah i think michael knows this guy he's a steel man at heart right this next scene is amazing michael calls dwight to ask about dunder mifflin's pricing for ed's tires he wants to undercut them right and this is when
dwight's internal conflict begins yeah he starts to waffle well because charles has invited him to drinks michael never invited him to drinks i know so he tells michael something's come up and michael's like oh my gosh is it mose did you cover up the well what is that backstory i don't know has mose fallen in the well of course he has he's probably fallen and been gone for like two days and then they find him in the well i love comedy like that it just throw away i just throw it away michael's not getting it he's not dwight starts kind of talking in code he's kind of like things are changing fast and you know there's a cool new guy and i don't think he'd like it if i helped even my personal hero and michael's like what are you talking about what are you talking about
so pam and ryan are like have to write on a notepad to help michael understand what dwight is saying and then steve is michael reads the notepad all the expressions that come over steve's face as michael figures this out i was blown away i said give steve all of the awards and that's why i drew a trophy seriously though this is an amazing performance it's so subtle and nuanced and steve i loved every single thing you did as michael being clueless and then not believing the note they're holding up but then figuring it out and then being like oh my god and then being betrayed like all of it it is really hard to play realization as an actor yeah because you know the information you had to memorize it you had to read the script you know where the scene is going yes and so to
play all of that it is like one of the hardest things to do as an actor and then to do it comedically amazing amazing we got a fan question about this scene from kelton o who said how is it that pam and ryan can hear both sides of this phone call yeah they seem to hear dwight so clearly through the phone well this is very funny kelton because rain was actually right off camera yeah doing his side of the phone call we could totally hear him rain actually had to come into work that day he did not have anything else to shoot all he did was stand off camera and read his side of the phone call it's actually a thing it's called doing off-camera work and that is often how different sides of a phone call are done we did not have the capability to like call in to that office right
like we did upstairs because it was a closet and a fakie phone yes i thought i could see how they were cheating it a little because michael is kind of holding the phone out so you would assume if you had the volume pretty high up it's a tiny room that you guys could probably hear we also had a fan catch from my are who said this angela what this went right to my heart she said i noticed a paper pro stapler on pam and ryan's table and my mom actually works for the company that sells these staplers it originated in pennsylvania before merging with bostich could this be why the stapler was used in this episode i don't know mya but i brought my paper pro stapler today you did i gotta try it out all right i brought champagne jenna brought a stapler here it is
now watch do i get to do it yes i am gonna do it with a single finger right wait here i now i wish i brought a regular stapler i had meant to bring a regular stapler i'm sure there is one okay ready watch this can you hear the clicking mech listen to the air pressure i heard that it is amazing try it okay i'm gonna try it staple something i'm gonna staple something it's not a regular stapler where you get a good junk it's like okay that's very hard you don't you can do it with one finger okay ready oh yes i see what you're talking about there's like a spring or something i say shut up i bought you a paper pro stapler sam i have one for you oh my god kassie i have one for you oh my gosh thank you you need to have it here's the last thing i'll say about the stapler
i think um i don't think you're done talking about it don't make that promise sometimes when we do these acting jobs you acquire a new skill maybe that you didn't have before when i did blades of glory i had to train with a ice skating coach i learned how to be quite a good ice skater sure when i did walk hard i took a little bit of horse riding lessons it's like a fun perk you get these skills right sometimes you get introduced to an item i remember when i did splitting up together there was just this amazing set of pajamas that i'd never heard of before and after wearing them on the show i bought three pairs i am now a lifelong fan of sass shoes exactly that is what this paper pro stapler was for me and it was all thanks to michael scott paper company well
there you go before we go to break i have one more thing to point out about this scene it's at six minutes 11 seconds it is a very good shot of our second goldfish oh yeah our first goldfish was orange that goldfish is gone this week it is a red orange white and black spotted fish and we got a letter from jess l who said i spent 10 years working in pet stores as an aquatic specialist and pet industry employees have been wondering for years whether or not the changing of the goldfish were a planned bit now we said last week it was yeah but she goes on to say anyone who works in fish departments knows goldfish deaths are common and a lot of us in the industry assume that the props people chose to make a bit out of the situation and just so you know
goldfish should have about 10 gallons of water per fish and it requires filtration to truly thrive in captivity she i think wanted us to know that because any of you out there with goldfish trying to keep them alive that could really help i think that's solid advice all right that's all i got well i have something delicious coming up with jim and andy that i can't wait to share who it just brought me so much joy and why don't we take a break and i'll come back with that i can't wait all right we are back i love this jim and andy scene jim is going to approach andy and he's he's gonna say hey andy you know what i've been thinking about what you said andy's like noish and jim's like i just don't know if i can do it andy's like that's interesting because
i hear what you're saying is that you want to do it which means you can do it believe me i broke up with angela and i'm like the happiest guy ever i mean i am so happy i am so happy like total freedom you know and jim says it's just that pam gets me through the day like i really rely on her i'm pretty emotionally needy and andy says and you know what i'm here for you let me be your traveling pants mm-hmm that was all scripted and in the script it says that jim and andy do a little knuckles bump yeah and they just simply say knuckles and that's the end of the scene okay well in our version jim goes to give the knuckles and andy leans in and puts his cheek in front of the knuckles and jim just starts to laugh and he's like dude you know i meant knuckles and he's like yeah knuckles
all right so ed just improvised that that whole moment go to eight minutes 26 seconds john is laughing at ed because he didn't know ed was gonna lean his face into the knuckle bump and it made it in and it just brought me joy because i just see these two guys and i see their friendship at eight minutes 26 seconds well when andy said i'll be your traveling pants that made me think of our director ken quapis who directed the sisterhood of the traveling pants yes and you and i went together to go see it i remember watching that movie because there was this really yes handsome it made us want to go to greece remember after that movie we're like we should go to greece we really should we should still go to greece we should well now we have
another scene out by the dumpster michael is gonna meet dwight again but guess what it's a setup oh yeah charles is there mm-hmm and charles is gonna tell michael to leave dunder mifflin alone and to stop pestering dwight for info i have two things to point out about this scene what are they the first one is from the shooting draft script and it's something that did not make it in the episode and i really wish it had michael immediately notices dwight's shirt yeah yeah and he says why are you dressed like that and he turns to charles and goes are you making him wear that what about his attack readiness you fool oh what a great callback i know i thought it was so sweet that michael was like oh yeah dwight has to wear short sleeves so he can attack someone yes i had
asked james carry if he would send me the call sheets for this episode there were a few things i wanted to investigate and i noticed that there was a note for this scene that said we need to shoot this scene at 3 30 p.m with three exclamation points i asked randy about this why yeah did idris have to go somewhere why 3 30 yeah he said it was the light oh that this section of the alleyway was on the far side of stage two and it was kind of a deep canyon he said between the stage and the hedges it was on the far side of the warehouse where we filmed the warehouse scenes yes and he said it's really really difficult to hide lights there so you have to use natural light and if you shoot it too early or too late the sun is blocked by the hedges or by the warehouse but i guess at
3 30 the angle is just right so i guess at 3 30 is when we had our bird funeral it must have been 3 30 in the alley i am thinking of how many scenes i had in that alley that's where angeline dwight would meet and she gave him sprinkles list of ointments and things like that and years later that's where i say jazz is stupid so it's all 3 30 in the alley you can set your watch by it well michael's gonna return to michael scott paper company and he's gonna try to tell them what happened and basically he got a pee-filled water balloon thrown in his face that's what he tells pam and ryan yes i mean they're like clearly at some point in his life that actually happened right must have oh that's terrible well they have to really decipher what that means
so they can figure out what the heck is happening well michael's gonna call dwight and he says i'm gonna steal all your clients and i'm gonna kill them in front of you yeah little i'm gonna come at you and i'm gonna come at you hard and then both dwight and michael try to call dwight's biggest client the whale mr showfeld from harper collins harper collins who is publishing our book office bff i know jenna when i rewatched this i was like oh my gosh this is synchronicity does this mean our book is gonna be printed on dunder mifflin paper what that would be amazing i mean that's they're a client right our book is being published like on the east coast it was really cool though because of all the book publishers out there
we're with harper collins and then dwight says harper collins and i was like oh my god i know should we give a book update by the way i want everyone to know we made it through that crazy document i figured it out angela figured it out that's saying something listen she didn't think she was gonna figure it out and i said you can do it i really had a moment you guys like for real where i was like um this isn't gonna happen and i'm sorry this is i can't do it but then i did it you did it mm-hmm i made myself a little cheat sheet mm-hmm that i kept by my computer oh yeah i mean listen i hope i did it i know we haven't got any feedback on it yet maybe we're gonna get like a note back that was like well way to go ladies you completely f'd it up i know and okay
so we have two more rounds of that and then the book is like locked and it goes to the printer oh lordy so yeah can't make any changes i know oh it's coming up i showed it to my kids yeah i showed them the photo layout and they were like oh my gosh because it's finally a book do you know what i mean it's not just like you and i turning in all these pages yes and it looks like a book visually in a pdf i showed it to leigh uh-huh and i said oh do you want to see how the photos kind of lay out and i thought he would look at it honestly i thought he would just glance at it yeah then he'd be like oh my god it looks cool he went through every single page like but like he was compelled to he was like this is amazing aw he was like dr tibido lee said amazing lee said
amazing he said it's so personal it's wow he's like these pictures he already knew the stories right and he just was like people are gonna love this that's what he said and it meant so much to me because we you know yeah sometimes you make something in a bubble and you don't know right we like it we love it so to me that oh that was such a confidence boost oh yeah that's what i needed to try to figure out the formatting document i needed that boost oh i needed a glass of wine well let's get back to the episode michael does finally get mr scofield on the phone by promising him a set of tickets to the penguins game the wilkesbury penguins game look what i'm wearing and angela is wearing her very own personal wilkesbury penguins
hockey jersey with her name on the back yeah i'm number one kenzie so in 2007 i went to the office convention with craig robinson kate flannery and brian bombgartner and we all went to a wilkesbury penguins game we got to go out on the ice we got to meet tux their mascot and we all got a jersey i've kept it all these years and i wore it today for our 100th episode that is so cool here's our picture jenna i'll show you look at us on the ice oh my gosh is that cool it was such a fun day were you nervous when you were walking on the ice i was just wear your regular shoes i was and i had these little boots on and i was like dear lord please don't let me bust my butt in front of all these people did they have little carpets down or no at the beginning but
then we walked all the way to the center and there was no more carpet yes i got to go to the all-stars game in st louis oh so cool and i got to be like a coach on the sideline it was really fun yes and then at the end i had to walk out on the ice yeah and i was so nervous right that i was gonna fall and david pastornack from the boston bruins he came over and he like gave me his arm and it was like a big fangirl moment for me well i held kate flannery's arm who did the penguins play that day oh they played the albany river rats oh yeah i just love hockey i can't say it more i have to say it was a really fun time well michael's thing with the tickets is gonna work because dwight is gonna get a call from mr scofield and he's
gonna say he's leaning toward michael scott paper company so dwight calls michael he's like i will agree to meet you 100 feet from our original meeting place they're not gonna meet at their same secret location mix it up guys 100 feet away at high noon yes and michael tells dwight to walk 100 feet toward the sun but it's right above you it's not possible twice clearly confused i have a whole thing about dwight's undies oh yes we're gonna see some green undies on dwight of course of course we will not just undies but whole torso the whole shebang there is nothing rain wilson loves more than exposing his torso it's exposing dwight's belly it's true i had to know i took a screen grab i texted it to rain and i said rain are these your green undies were they
actually yours and this is what he wrote back and i quote those were provided by wardrobe my love aw so i said oh my god rain you had to have a wardrobe meeting about underwear and these were the pair that were picked it's interesting because if you look there are a few other times on the show where dwight is in his underwear like when he's sleeping on the couch yes we had a fan question from joanna k margaret f and natalia l during the scene where dwight is buckling his pants after showing michael that he isn't wearing a wire do i hear a rooster crowing in the background yes guys yes you do it's at 13 minutes 34 seconds there was a house yeah in our vicinity and they had some chickens and a rooster and it was a challenge yeah because you can't make a rooster
not crow when it wants to crow also jenna do you remember the year that there was like a flock of parrots yes that like we're living in that tree and they parrots are so loud you guys are like so i was like and when they're in a group they get a bolster of confidence they really do they're super chatty i remember this because i was like kenneth paul who did my makeup i was like there is a flock of parrots and he said angela faith because he always called you by your first and middle name he said angela faith don't you mean a pandemonium of parrots is that what a group of parrots is called i guess so oh we also had a fan question from charlotte m she's wondering where the heck is rain wilson's mic pack right yeah i'll tell you what there was no mic pack they had to
capture all of his sound on a boom microphone only yeah they couldn't fit it under his paws so what has happened to you that's champagne that's the champagne talking that crept up on us it did slowly champagne sneaks up on you that's the problem with champagne champagne makes me fun it does yeah what can i expect from this afternoon i don't know i had to stop drinking it because i have to drive home lady we skipped something a while back and i want to bring it up it's when andy's in the kitchen and jim enters and he's doing like this whole melodrama of messing up a sales call he's beating himself up and he it's like he's in a soap opera yes and then he like dropped kicks his lunch across the room steps on it yes we got some fan mail people
wanted to know if that lunch bit was an improv it was not in fact in the script it said jim drop kicks his lunch bag so i just want to say what that means when there's that simple line in a script that says jim drop kicks his lunch bag when phil shay is going through a script and he sees that sentence he's gonna highlight that right he's gonna go to production and he's gonna say how many takes of this scene do you think we'll do how many lunch bags do i need to make how many sandwiches do i need to make all of it he'll probably also go to john and say what are the odds you improvised taking a bite of it after you kick it what kind of sandwich do you want in there everything he would be so meticulous and then he would have to make a bunch of identical
lunch bags and then like before we would have a crew member off camera ready to fly in that's the lingo fly in a new lunch bag and they would also probably have john try to kick it into the same corner every time yes that is how that little bitty sentence affected a bunch of people now lady it's time to go to alfredo's yeah michael pam and ryan are gonna go to alfredo's they're supposed to be meeting dwight there because they're supposed to be like reconciling at alfredo's pizza cafe dwight is such a good liar because i feel like the line is in the details and he knew he was never gonna meet michael for lunch no he's actually putting a fish in their ceiling yes he's sabotaging them he loves to sabotage he's stealing michael's rolodex right he knew he wasn't gonna go and michael
said how about coopers and dwight's like no i had fish last week alfredo's like this is really sneaky very much so yeah well randy told us that the vent or dwight throws the fish fish was not real and it was actually kind of difficult to construct that michael gallenberg had to consult with our builder tim james and they had to like drop the ceiling and create this vent and they also had to build in sort of like a plastic receptacle to catch that fish because the fish was real what it was a real fish it was not a prop fish no it was a real dead fish i mean it was like a fish they bought at the store right so it was a dead fish it was a dead fish yeah stinky dead fish wait a second let me understand this correctly they had to
build a fake ceiling yeah with a fake drop down with a fake vent that could also hold dead fish yeah it would have fallen through otherwise yeah i can't believe we didn't use a fakie fish i was shocked yeah randy said it was a real fish i wasn't there you know later when we come in and discover it we're totally faking that we smell it it was gone by then so wait a second at the end in that montage you guys take the fish out of the ceiling did you have to touch a real dead fish oh my gosh lady i first of all i did not remember that we did that scene even though i watched this episode three times i was clearly so distracted by white sleeves that you didn't notice you touched a fish and i have no memory of it but i mean i guess we did
according to randy i guess i did touch a dead fish have you ever done a prank like that no no i don't like pranks okay you know me i know you i in college i had a group of friends who got really into pranking they were like next level pranksters here's an example they took a dead fish and they put it in the back of this guy nick's toilet they lifted the back of the toilet and they put that fish in the toilet water you know that's in the back no one ever lifts that thing unless your toilet's not flushing and you've got to jiggle that little thing no one lifts the back of the toilet right no no yeah that fish was there a long time it gets so stinky it got so stinky we would go over to nick he lived in a house with a group of guys and we'd be like god nick your
house stinks he's like i know it's the plumbing or something i've had three different guys out here couldn't figure out what it was for like a month oh this is so disgusting it's so disgusting and then there's a certain point where the smell really zeroes in on one area and he finally lift the back thing and it was so foul it was like maggots and disgustingness he wasn't noticing that like the water in his toilet was affected i know what to tell you lady i don't know what to tell you did nick find this amusing oh it was on after that it really the pranking got really out of control they got really into pranking here's my thing about pranking what for me personally to like get through a day yeah just with my own thoughts in my head and everything life is throwing
at me yes you know what i don't need a prank your prank yeah i don't need it yeah although i did do one christmas prank once what someone what it was like you know a group thing and you were specifically supposed to do a joke gift right and i had to come up with like a joke christmas present so what i did was the roommate of the person's name who i picked yeah i said over the course of one month will you slowly just sort of steal things from your roommate like a single shoe like i gave him a list of oh you're the slow play yeah i was just like have little things go missing like maybe favorite coffee mug and then at the very end toothbrush and then at the christmas party i had wrapped up all of the missing items into a box and then that was the gift oh that's kind of
fun all your stuff that's gone missing for a month yeah that was my joke gift i like that i am not much of a prankster i'm a lame pranker well i'm glad you're a lame pranker lady because i don't want pranks in my life and you're my bff and so i'm happy that i don't have a bff that is like devoted to pranking yeah that would really suck wouldn't it it really would i have a location breakdown for alfredo's pizza cafe let's hear it this was a restaurant in woodland hills california called nicolas and it is owned by a husband and wife that were friends with our set designer michael gallenberg oh and randy said that we did not have to do much redressing of this restaurant at all we were able to pretty much just use it as it was that's great randy would also like you to
know that nicolas has the best chop salad in the valley i looked it up it looks really good and it cost sixteen dollars i would love a chop salad right now i know that's what we should do after let's swing by nicolas or something and have a chop salad have a chop salad well in order to shoot this scene we had to get there at 6 30 in the morning and we had to shoot at 7 30 because we had to do it before the restaurant was open but after this bj and i just got to go home that's all i had to do that day i remember i was back home by like 10 a.m my work day was done steve and the rest the crew did a whole day of locations but while i was looking at the call sheet i saw this fascinating detail which was the van schedule oh do you remember these van schedules when we would
我知道尼古拉斯餐厅有山谷里最棒的切达沙拉，我查过了，看起来真不错，而且只要十六美元，我现在好想吃一份切达沙拉，我知道我们之后该做什么了，我们顺路去一趟尼古拉斯什么的，吃一份切达沙拉，吃一份切达沙拉，为了拍这场戏，我们得在早上六点半赶到那里，七点半就得开拍，因为必须在餐厅开门前拍完，但拍完这个之后，我和BJ就可以直接回家了，那天我只需要做这些，我记得我大概十点钟就回到家了，我的工作日就结束了，史蒂夫和剧组其他人继续去外景地拍了一整天，不过当我在看通告单时，我看到了一个极其迷人的细节，那就是面包车时间表，噢，你还记得当我们在外景地拍戏时的这些面包车时间表吗，女郎，不，你记不得了，噢，看吧，这就是我以前最喜欢做的事，我会把通告单上的每一个细节都读得滚瓜烂熟，没错，你确实会这样，我到片场时会问，为什么XS好莱坞会在这里，而你就会说，安吉拉，通告单上写着呢，他们可能上周就在你的化妆车里发过备忘录了，她真的会那样，她的地板上会堆一叠备忘录，文件被随意扔在一旁，好吧，所以当你在外景地拍戏时，你把车停好，他们会在一个大停车场里搭起发型和化妆车，他们把这叫做大本营，这就是餐饮服务商搭建餐篷的地方，也是你吃午饭的地方，但很多时候，大本营距离实际拍摄地点非常远，这次就是这样，从大本营坐面包车到尼古拉斯餐厅大约需要15分钟的车程
shoot on location lady no you don't oh see this is the thing i used to love to do where i read every detail of a call sheet yes you would i would show up and be like why is xs hollywood here and you'd be like angela it's on the call sheet and they put a memo in your trailer probably last week i stepped right over that she really would there'd be a pile of memos on her floor the papers to the side all right so when you shoot on location you park your car and they have the hair and makeup trailers in a big parking lot and they call it base camp this is where the caterers will set up their food tent it's where you eat lunch but a lot of times base camp is really far away from the actual shooting location and that was the case here it was about a 15 minute van ride to get from
所以他们必须安排一辆面包车时间表来接送所有人去片场，上面是这样写的：早餐将在5点15分供应，然后你可以乘坐六辆去片场面包车中的一辆，它们分别在早上5点42分、6点、6点12分出发，他们将这辆车指定为灯光和电力组专车，6点30分，最后还有一辆车在早上6点42分出发，上面用全大写字母写着：这是末班车，你绝对不想坐这辆车，千万别坐，不，不，不，不，还有专为演员和群众演员准备的额外穿梭巴士，定于早上7点出发，所以当时的安排是，剧组人员先到那里，架好所有的灯光，然后演员们再抵达，发型和化妆师会和演员们坐同一辆车，这就是面包车时间表，制作这个面包车时间表是兰迪的工作
base camp to nicholas restaurant so they had to have a van schedule to shuttle all of these people to set and here's what it said it said breakfast would be available as a 515 and then you could take one of six vans to set they left at 5 42 a.m 6 a.m 6 12 a.m and they designated this van for our grip and electric crew 6 30 a.m and then there was one last van at 6 42 a.m and in all caps it said this is the late van you did not want to be on the don't do it no no no no there were also additional shuttles for the cast and the background actors that were set to leave at 7 a.m so the idea was the crew would get there set up all the lights and then the actors would land the hair and makeup folks would ride with the actors that's the van schedule that was randy's job to make that van
他干得太棒了，所以德怀特最终没能去成餐厅，他打电话来说他撞到了一头熊，迈克尔竟然就这么信了，不仅仅是迈克尔，我得告诉你们，帕姆和瑞恩甚至连眼皮都没眨一下，迈克尔说德怀特撞到了一头熊时，他们甚至都没有把视线从菜单上移开，但他在路上了，德怀特到底撞过多少头熊，为什么这事这么让人信服，他们回到迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，发现他们被盗了，德怀特打电话来，迈克尔说：我们没时间闲聊，我们被盗了，而帕姆和瑞恩再次反应道：肯定是德怀特干的，是的，这就是德怀特开始从通讯录里挖走客户的时候，为了报复他，迈克尔要吃掉他带回来的肉丸帕尔马干酪三明治，这太搞笑了，因为德怀特说：我早就知道你会这么干，所以我才故意让你点这个，因为这是他们菜单上最难吃的东西，然后史蒂夫表现得那么嫌弃，为什么看史蒂夫这样觉得那么搞笑呢，他对任何东西感到嫌弃，对任何食物感到嫌弃，都搞笑极了，好吧，在随性星期五里，他要吃掉所有人的午餐，那段真的非常非常好笑，我迫不及待想聊到那里去了，那里还有一些很棒的搞笑花絮呢，听着，这里还有一个被删减的场景，当德怀特挖走所有人的客户时，他真的对瑞恩过分了，因为瑞恩的叔叔选择支持德怀特而不是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，什么？是的，而且还有一些帕姆非常犀利的吐槽，我们得听听这个，德怀特刚刚搞定了霍华德家族干洗店的戴夫叔叔，那个混蛋在狠狠地压我们的价，他其实是在亏本经营，自己掏腰包
schedule he did a fantastic job so dwight never makes it to the restaurant he calls and says he hit a bear and michael just believes it not just michael i will have you know that pam and ryan don't even raise an eyebrow they don't even look up from their menu when michael says dwight hit a bear but he's on the way how many bears has dwight hit why is this so believable they get back to michael scott paper company they discover they've been robbed dwight calls michael is like we i don't have time to talk we've been robbed and once again pam and ryan are like it was dwight yeah this is when dwight is gonna start poaching the clients off the rolodex and to get back at him michael is gonna eat his meatball parm that he brought back for him which is so funny because dwight says i knew
倒贴差价，这就是我的家人，你惹了我家人，我可不保证会做出什么举动，你什么时候对自己的行动负过责？少烦我，你这个泼妇，嘿，嘿，嘿，这话听起来有点不太合适，这话听起来有点不太合适，他说不出个所以然来，我太喜欢瑞恩和帕姆之间的那种竞争关系了，我简直为之疯狂，我也超喜欢，我是说，在这个时期能和这些家伙们一起工作，我真的太爱了，我敢打赌这一定超级有趣，好了，现在我们要进入一个非常有趣的桥段，迈克尔一边打着德怀特打来的电话，一边走进哈珀柯林斯出版社，他说：我要让你听听我如何抢走你最大的客户，德怀特说：不，然后挂了电话冲进车里，一路上都在听着，这太搞笑了，对吧，他在车里的时候说
you were gonna do that and that's why i made you order it because it's the worst thing on their menu and then the way steve is so disgusted by it why is it so funny to watch steve anything that he's disgusted with anything with food it's hilarious well in casual friday he's gonna eat everybody's lunch and it's very very funny i can't wait to get to that there's some good bloopers from that too listen there was a deleted scene as dwight is poaching everyone's clients he really crosses the line with ryan because ryan's uncle chooses dwight over the michael scott paper company what yeah and there's some really good pam sass we got to hear it dwight just got howard family dry cleaners uncle dave well jerk is undercutting us big time he is actually taking a loss and paying the difference
纸张就是粪肥，按时送达就是土壤，我也把这句话记下来了，我需要把这句话印在马克杯上吗？我们可能真的需要把它印在马克杯上，纸张就是粪肥，我们有一个来自悉尼·S的粉丝提问，她说：你们是怎么拍摄德怀特开车去斯科菲尔德先生办公室那场戏的？史蒂夫真的在电话那头吗？不，史蒂夫根本不在电话那头，我跟兰迪聊过这件事，雷恩是真的在开车，他是自由驾驶，车子没有拖挂在任何东西后面，我看起来倒挺像的，就看他拐进停车场的那种架势，是的，全程都是这样，所以他们找了洛杉矶警察局的摩托车警员开路，这样就不会有人干扰拍摄或是雷恩开车，是的，没错，后面还跟着一辆剧组的面包车，但他们是这样拍出那个镜头的，马特
out of pocket that's my family when you mess with my family i can't be responsible for my actions when are you ever responsible for your actions get off my ass you hag hey hey hey something about that seems inappropriate something about that seems inappropriate you can't put his finger on it i love the ryan pam like rivalry i just live for it i love it too i mean i just loved working with these guys for this period of time i bet it was so much fun well now we're gonna get into a pretty fun bit where michael is gonna walk in to harper collins with dwight on the phone he's like i'm gonna let you listen to me still your biggest client and dwight's like no and takes off and he gets in the car all the while listening that was so funny right in the car when he was like
索恩，我们的摄像师坐在前排，噢，在拍雷恩，我们的录音师本·帕特里克坐在后排录音，我们的导演保罗·费格也坐在后排，兰迪，那可不是个大后座，我坐过那辆车，那车小得要命，我知道，兰迪说我们当时没有双向通话设备，那太不可靠了，所以兰迪猜想，保罗·费格当时是在念史蒂夫的台词，好让雷恩能做出反应，太棒了，我真希望当时能有一张那四个家伙坐在车里的照片，我们来聊聊德怀特终于到达斯科菲尔德先生办公室时发生了什么，我简直爱死这段了，我当时特别想知道这是剧本写好的还是即兴发挥的，所以德怀特先是冲了进去，首先他换上了他的
paper is the manure and on time delivery is the soil i wrote down that quote too do i need that on a mug we might need it on a mug paper is the manure we had a fan question from sydney s who said how did you guys film that scene of dwight driving to mr scofield's office was steve really on the other end of the phone no steve was not on the other end of the phone and i talked with randy about this rain is really driving he's free driving he is not hooked up to anything it looked like it to me just the way he pulled into the parking lot yeah the whole time so they had la pd officers on motorcycles so no one would sort of interfere with the shot or rain driving yes correct and there's also a crew van following behind but here's how they got that shot matt
芥末黄衬衫，我太喜欢这个细节了，超爱这个细节，然后当他走到前台时，他做了一个疯狂的旋转动作，接着德怀特说：旋转动作，当时我就想，这是雷恩即兴发挥的吗？我一定要搞清楚，珍娜，剧本里百分之百写了，所有的东西，甚至连旋转动作，全都有，我找到了雷恩过去的一个采访，他说他有一次做了个前空翻，他说他觉得当他们回看的时候，这会显得格外神不知鬼鬼不觉，但回看时看起来quote就像是一只海牛在海洋世界里跳芭蕾，他还说他们大概拍了五次，我还顺便整理了一个关于斯科菲尔德先生前台接待员的客串演员资料，她由安吉拉·坎波拉·桑德斯饰演，她是《办公室》自第四季以来的选角助理，这是她唯一的演艺经历，但她扮演了斯科菲尔德先生的
sone our camera operator was in the front seat oh filming rain our sound engineer ben patrick was in the backseat recording sound and our director paul feig was also in the backseat randy that was not a big backseat i have been in that car that is tiny i know and randy said we did not have a two-way phone setup it was just too unreliable and so randy's guess is that paul feig was reading steve's dialogue so that rain could react to it yeah amazing i wish we had a picture of those four guys in the car can we talk about what happens when dwight arrives at mr scott field's office finally i lived for this i had to know if this was scripted or improvised so dwight is going to run in first of all he's changing into his
前台，我们选角办公室里的几乎每个人都在某个时刻客串过这部剧，我太喜欢这个了，我也是，德怀特简直是在给自己挖一个巨大的深坑，因为他根本不懂迈克尔的客户通讯录，也不懂迈克尔的颜色编码信息，迈克尔有一段对着镜头的独白，他说：我把所有的信息都用颜色做了编码，我写了『gay sun』和绿色，绿色代表通行，所以我知道该闭嘴就闭嘴，是的，橙色代表橙色，很高兴你没提这事，大多数颜色都代表别说出来，是的，但德怀特并不知道这一点，是的，所以德怀特基本上是在把所有按颜色编码不能说出来的事情全盘托出，好吧，在我们结束迈克尔和......等等，迈克尔，这一集，你知道那是香槟吧，我知道，在你的香槟脑子里，你给
mustard shirt i loved that detail love that detail and then when he gets to the receptionist he does this crazy spin move and then dwight says spin move and i was like did rain improvise that i've got to know jenna it was 100 in the script everything even the spin move all of it i found an old interview with rain where he said that one time he did a somersault and he said he thought that it would look extra stealthy when they watched it back it looked quote like a manatee doing ballet at sea world he also said they did about five takes i also have a little guest star breakdown for mr scofield's receptionist she was played by angela campola sanders who was our casting associate on the office since season four this is her only acting credit but she played mr scofield's
每个人都起了一个外号，迈克尔，迈克尔，德怀特，嗯，我觉得我们应该回去把安迪和吉姆这条故事线做个收尾，好的，顺便说一句，我们俩都不得不停止喝香槟了，我们真的是，这太有趣了，苏格兰威士忌加代糖感觉就像是魔力药水，但香槟让我们觉得：我现在不会说话了，是的，我其实还是真的很喜欢苏格兰威士忌加代糖，我也是，我必须得说，这真的是一款很棒的饮料，我们收到了一些粉丝的来信，他们说这基本上就是一杯老式鸡尾酒，如果我们再加一点橙味苦精的话，喝起来就是那个味道，没错，因为我想你大概会往苏格兰威士忌里加一点糖，一种捣碎的含糖糖浆，所以代糖起的就是这个作用，是的，但香槟只会让我们变成：什么？我们在
receptionist pretty much everyone in our casting office made it into the episode at some point i love that i do too dwight is about to dig himself into a big old hole because he doesn't understand michael's rolodex or michael's color coding info michael has a talking head where he says i color code all my info i wrote gay sun and green green means go so i know to go ahead and shut up about it yes and orange means orange are glad you didn't bring it up most colors mean don't say it yeah but dwight doesn't know that yes so dwight is basically saying all the things that are color coded to not be said right well before we wrap up this heavy competition between mike wait this mike this episode you know that's the champagne i know in the champagne you have
聊什么？发生了什么？我知道，好吧，好吧，看，我知道，我心想：我在说什么呢？好吧，所以安迪和吉姆，安迪要告诉整个开放式办公区的员工说吉姆很难过，而菲利斯则会说：嗯，安迪，我觉得吉姆只是在逗你玩百，然后就是吉姆在厨房里通过百叶窗向外张望、脸上带着那种标志性坏笑的得意特写，我们收到了来自蕾亚·H和普内特·B的粉丝提问：我们能聊聊吉姆这一集表现得有多像个混蛋吗？安迪当时真的很支持吉姆，并且是真心关心吉姆，虽然安迪的关心可能用错了地方或者有点爱管闲事，但我觉得他的出发点是好的，我们真的很想听听你对吉姆捉弄安迪这个恶作剧的看法，因为我们觉得这个恶作剧可能有点刻薄，我不太喜欢，我也不喜欢，我确实觉得这是一个很刻薄的玩笑，我的意思是，我们已经知道了，我本来就不喜欢恶作剧，尤其不喜欢那种以牺牲别人为代价、玩弄别人情绪的恶作剧，对吧，我觉得他对安迪那种爱管闲事的干预反应过度了，而且吉姆最后对安迪说了一段很暖心的话，他说：听着，我知道安吉拉伤了你的心，但你会找到别人的，真的会的，所以我觉得那是编剧们在试图表明：你知道的，吉姆不是个坏家伙，也许他是在试图向安迪展示些什么，但我就是不喜欢这个恶作剧，我也是，好吧，很高兴我们讨论了这个，是的，我们跟你们站在同一边，所以这一集的结尾是更多奶酪球的欢乐桥段，迈克尔、瑞恩和帕姆，他们试图看
a nickname for everyone in your champagne brain mike mike dwighty um okay i think we should go back and wrap up this andy jim storyline okay we both had to stop drinking champagne by the way we did it just it's so interesting scotch and splenda was like waboo waboo but champagne we're like i can't talk right now yeah i still really do love the scotch and splenda me too i have to say it's a really good drink and we got some letters from people who said it's basically an old fashioned if we'd added a few orange bitters and that's what it tasted like that's right because i guess you would add like a sugar yeah a muddled kind of sugary syrup to the scotch and so that's what the splenda is doing yeah but champagne just makes us go what what are we
自己嘴里能塞下多少个奶酪球，32个，那是纪录，对吧，然后电话响了，迈克尔接了电话，而他嘴里塞满了奶酪球，我们都在大笑，而正当这发生时，你可以听到迈克尔的一段画外独白，他说他想开创一家公司，而不是发动一场战争，好吧，这段独白是后来补录的，原本的剧本里并没有，史蒂夫是在我们拍完原版剧集几周后补拍的，所有这些我们吃奶酪球的镜头，原本是打算放在冷开场结尾的，所以所有这些原本都要放在剧集的最开始，是的，但他们觉得以帕姆打着哈欠拿到奶酪球作为冷开场结尾会更有趣，于是他们给这一集
talking about what's happening i know okay all right see i know i'm like what am i talking about okay so andy and jim andy is going to tell the whole bullpen that jim is upset and phyllis is gonna be like um andy i think jim is just messing with you and then there's that smug shot of jim in the kitchen looking out through the blinds with that grin on his face we had a fan question from reya h and punet b can we talk about how douchey jim is being in this episode andy was being really supportive and genuinely cared for jim and while andy's concern might have been misguided or nosy i think it came from a good place we'd really like to get your take on this prank that jim pulls on andy because we think the prank might have been a little mean spirited i didn't care for it
安排了这个全新的奶酪球彩蛋，这并不是这一集的原始彩蛋，所以，与其让奶酪球作为片头和片尾的呼应，原本其实有一个片尾彩蛋，而且我们确实拍了，我想跟你们分享一下，所以安迪当时在会议室里，他在变卖他的婚礼用品，他依然意志坚定，依然坚定，好吧，你知道的，他没能从吉姆和帕姆那里卖出去，所以在彩蛋里，他在把东西卖给其他同事，大家都在竞价买东西，斯坦利买下了大米袋，而克里德也决定参与进来，我觉得我们必须听一听其中的一小段，斯坦利，你来这里干什么？我来买大米，成交，100袋大米，斯坦利·哈德森，克里德，你想要一件崭新帅气的燕尾服作为你的葬礼服吗？我要下半身，我想以我来时的同样方式离开，赤裸上身，然后其他人也开始纷纷出价，对东西提出疑问，安吉拉没有出现在这个场景中，但她路过时有一段独白，这在拍摄剧本里是有的，我不知道我为什么这么沮丧，我想我一直以为安迪会把我们婚礼的东西留着，以防万一，现在这太蠢了，以防万一我嫁给了别人，而他决定给我们办一场婚礼，我告诉过你这很蠢，我想里面确实有一些安吉拉喜欢的东西，是的，或许她还希望这些东西能重新派上用场，所以，事情就是这样，各位，100集了，噢天哪，我们赶在假期前完成了，是的，我很高兴，因为那段时期总是非常疯狂，万圣节到新年，这可以说是冲刺到年底，我总是这么说，好吧
i didn't either i i do think this is a mean spirited joke i mean we already know i don't like pranks and i don't love especially pranks that at someone's expense that play with their emotions right i think it was too big of a reaction to andy's kind of nosy meddling and he does have this nice speech jim at the end to andy he's like listen i know angela broke your heart but you're going to find someone else you really will so i feel like that was the moment where the writers were like you know jim's not a bad guy maybe he was trying to show andy something but i just didn't like the prank me either yeah well i'm glad we discussed that yeah we're with you so this episode ends with more cheese ball fun michael ryan and pam they're trying to see
听着，接下来我们要迎来几个假期休息时间，我们在感恩节放假，在圣诞节和新年放假，我们会播出一些精彩的剧集重播，并在片头加上有趣的小彩蛋，是的，所以一定要收听那些内容，不过听着，安吉拉，我们收到了这封信，因为你知道的，我说过我在查看邮件，对吧，来自苏珊娜·G，我想分享一下，我真的很感激，好的，我们听听看，苏珊娜说：不知道你们会不会看到这个，但我有些话想对你们俩说，首先，你们就是我的同类，你们傻乎乎的、吵吵闹闹的、真诚的、有条理的，珍娜，我也是，她把安吉拉归到有条理那一类去了，没关系，苏珊娜，但更重要的是，我注意到了你们对心理健康的重视，主要通过你们有时在播客之间
how many cheese puffs can they fit in their mouth 32 that's the record yeah and then the phone rings and michael answers it and he's got a mouth full of cheese puffs and we're all laughing and while this is happening you can hear a michael talking head where he's saying he wanted to start a company and not a war well this talking head was added later this was not in the original script steve shot this a couple weeks after we shot the original episode and all of this footage of us doing this cheese puffs bit yeah this was originally gonna be at the end of the cold open so it was all of that was going to live at the top of the episode yes but they thought it would be funnier to end the cold open on pam getting the cheese puffs while she's yawning and then they gave this episode
休息来体现，并不是所有播客都会这样做，作为粉丝，我总是翘首以盼下一周的播客，所以当我偶尔听到重播内容时，最初难免会觉得有点小失落，然而，这随之而来的往往是这样的想法：嗯，也许他们需要更多的准备时间，这样他们就不用牺牲陪伴家人的时间或自我关怀了，作为一个拼命三娘式的妈妈，我有着自己的职业生涯，有两个年幼的孩子，还有一个日程疯狂、需求繁多且压力巨大的执法部门老公，我的生活可以说是混乱不堪，至少可以这么说，但我越来越深刻地认识到，我和家人的稳定来自于不牺牲这两样东西，所以我赞赏你们坚持自己的价值观，同时还能做自己喜欢的事，并且有闺蜜相伴，这真是太幸福了，也许我全都猜错了，情况根本不是这样的，但如果我猜准了，我只想送上鼓励，继续按你们的方式坚持下去吧，无论何时更新，我都会期待下一周的播客，向你们俩发送虚拟拥抱，这太甜了，苏珊娜，你完全说对了，是的，我觉得自己被看见了，苏珊娜，是的，这对我意义重大，因为我觉得我和安吉拉是两个有着极强职业道德的女孩，我们热爱制作这个节目，但对我们来说同样重要的是，我们要留出假期时间、一点春假时间、一点夏日时光专门给我们的家人，是的，为了我们的心理健康休息，所以我们确实为此休假了，你知道的，这也意味着我们这里的团队也能放个假，没错，每个人都能放个假，所以谢谢你，苏珊娜，我真的非常感激，并且请知道，我们会在
this new tag with the cheese ball bit this was not the original tag for the episode so instead of this bookend of cheese puffs at the beginning and end there was a tag and we did film it and I want to share it with you guys so andy is in the conference room and he is selling off his wedding stuff he's determined still still well you know he didn't get buyers from gym and pam so in the tag he's selling it to the rest of the gang and they're all bidding on things stanley buys the rice bags and creed decides to get in on the action too i thought we had to hear a little bit of it why are you here stanley i'm here for the rice boom sold 100 bags of rice stanley Hudson creed how would you like a crispy new tuxedo for your funeral i'll take the bottom half
那些重播剧集的开头放一些有趣的内容，这样我们在休息期间就不会把你们晾在一边了，没错，各位，我真的想非常感谢克里德·布拉顿为我们录制了那么温馨的小片头，各位，他刚刚发行了一首新单曲，名叫《轻松呼吸》，可以在苹果音乐上收听，我想在我们说再见的时候，我们可以听一听其中的一小段，祝贺第100集，祝贺第100集，谢谢你们收听《办公室女士》，《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作，我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的制作人
i want to go out the same way i came in shirtless and everyone else starts making bids too that asking questions on things angela is not in the scene but she walks by and had this talking head it was in the shooting draft i don't know why i'm down i guess i always thought that andy would save the stuff from our wedding just in case now it's stupid just in case i married someone else and he decided to throw us a wedding i told you it was stupid i guess there were some things in there that angela liked yeah and maybe she hoped would make a comeback uh so there you have it guys 100 episodes oh my gosh we got it in just before the holidays yeah i'm glad because that's always like a very crazy time it is the halloween to new year it's a sprint to the end i always say well
是卡西·杰金斯，我们的录音师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科，我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》，想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitcherpremium.com，使用优惠码office即可免费试听一个月Stitcher Premium，本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
listen we're gonna have a few breaks coming up we do take a break at thanksgiving we take a break at christmas and new year's we will have some great reruns of episodes with fun little new stuff at the top yes so be sure to listen to that stuff but listen ang we got this letter because you know i said i was going through the mail yeah from susanna g and i wanted to share it i really appreciated it okay let's hear it susanna says not sure you'll see this but i wanted to say something to you both first you are my people you are silly loud honest organized jenna me too and just she did put angela in there for organize it's okay susanna but more importantly i noticed your value of mental health mainly depicted to me by the breaks that you take sometimes between podcast
听着，接下来的时间我们会休息几次，感恩节我们会休息，圣诞节和新年我们也会休息，我们将会有一些精彩的重播节目，开头会加入一些有趣的新内容，是的，所以一定要去听那些内容，但是听着，安，我们收到了这封信，因为你知道我说过我要查看邮件，是的，来自苏珊娜·G，我想分享一下，我真的很感激，好的，我们听听看，苏珊娜说，不确定你们是否会看到这个，但我想对你们两个说几句话，首先，你们是我的同道中人，你们既搞笑、吵闹、诚实又有条理，珍娜，我也是，她确实把安吉拉归类为有条理的人，没关系，苏珊娜，但更重要的是，我注意到了你们对心理健康的重视，主要通过你们有时在播客之间休息来体现
episodes not all podcasts do that and as a fan i always look forward to listening to next week's episode so when i hear rerun content at times it's initially a bummer however it's always followed by thoughts of well perhaps they needed more prep time so that they didn't have to sacrifice family time or self-care and as a hustling mom with a career of my own two small children and a law enforcement hubby with crazy schedules demands and stresses my life is chaotic to say the least but i'm learning more and more my stability and that of my family comes from not sacrificing those two things so i commend you for staying committed to your values and still getting to do what you love and with your bestie what a blessing maybe i got all this wrong and that's not what's going
剧集之间，并不是所有的播客都会这样做，作为粉丝，我总是期待着收听下一周的节目，所以当我有时听到重播内容时，起初会觉得有点失落，然而，这之后总是会让人想到，或许她们需要更多的准备时间，这样她们就不必牺牲家庭时间或自我关照，作为一个忙碌的妈妈，我有自己的事业、两个幼儿和一个有着疯狂日程、要求和压力的执法丈夫，我的生活可以说是混乱不堪，但我越来越认识到，我和家人的稳定性来自于不牺牲这两样东西，所以我赞赏你们坚持自己的价值观，同时还能做自己喜欢的事，而且是和你们的闺蜜一起，真是个福气，也许我完全理解错了，事情根本不是这样的
on at all but if i'm on the nose i simply want to offer encouragement to keep it up your way i'll be waiting for next week's episode whenever you get to it sending virtual hugs to you both that is so sweet susanna you got it a hundred percent right yeah i feel seen susanna yes it really meant a lot to me because i feel like angela and i are two gals with a very strong work ethic we love making this show but it is also important to us that we reserve holiday time a little spring break time a little summer time just for our families yeah for our mental health breaks and so we do take time off for that you know it also means that our team here gets a break that's right everyone gets a break so thank you susanna i really appreciate it and just know that we will put
但如果我猜对了，我只想提供鼓励，让你们继续保持这种方式，无论何时你们更新，我都会等待下一周的节目，向你们两个发送虚拟的抱抱，这太贴心了，苏珊娜，你完全说对了，是的，我觉得被理解了，苏珊娜，是的，这对我真的很重要，因为我觉得安吉拉和我是两个工作伦理非常强的女性，我们热爱制作这个节目，但对我们来说同样重要的是，我们要留出假期时间、一点春假时间、一点暑假时间专门留给我们的家人们，是的，为了我们的心理健康休息，所以我们确实会为此休假，你知道的，这也意味着我们这里的团队也能休息，没错，每个人都能休息，所以谢谢你，苏珊娜，我真的很感激，也请知道，我们会在
some fun stuff at the top of those rerun episodes so that we don't leave you hanging on those breaks that's right and you guys i really want to say thank you so much to creed bratton as well for doing that sweet little intro for us and you guys he has a new single that just dropped it's called breathe easy it's available on apple music and i thought we could listen to a little bit of it as we say goodbye happy 100th episode happy 100 oh thank you for listening to office ladies office ladies is produced by earwolf jenna fischer and angela kenzie our show is executive produced by kody fischer our producer
那些重播节目的开头加入一些有趣的内容，这样我们在休息期间就不会让你们悬着了，没错，你们大家，我真的想非常感谢克里德·布拉顿为我们做了这么甜蜜的小引子，你们知道吗，他刚发布了一首新单曲，叫做《深呼吸》，可以在苹果音乐上收听，我想我们可以一边说再见一边听一点这首歌，庆祝第一百期节目快乐，庆祝第一百期快乐，哦，感谢收听《办公室女士》，《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作，我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的制作人
is kassie jerkins our sound engineer is sam keefer and our associate producer is ainsley boobaco our theme song is rubber tree by creed bratton for ad-free versions of office ladies go to stitcher premium dot com for a free one month trial of stitcher premium use code office There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人工是艾恩斯利·布巴科，我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》，想要无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 stitcherpremium.com，要免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 office。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。